Amazon is raising its minimum wage to $15.
An hour. What's that? Amazon just what? $15 an hour,
$15 an hour,
$15 an hour.
$15. Hi.
This is what you might call a get rich quick scammer. That is, uh,
they like to mock people with nine to five jobs and tell you that you should go
tell your boss.
Off.
And that's basically it.
We're going to walk through his sales pitch and get to know more about our
little friend here. So.
So stick around.
What up guys do you want to easily ditch your nine to five and make six figures
a year working only one day a week from your laptop? I know.
I sure do. Who is this mysterious man?
Who's laughing at the idea of a nine to five job, right?
Because everyone who works nine to five jobs, they're losers,
losers work for a living. Are you kidding me?
Adrian G is his name and unbelievably dope.
That's a lot of subscribers. Okay. This guy is popular.
It seems like all the popular people are hopping on selling, get rich products,
right? They love it. They love selling to their gullible fans.
They're little fantasies. So he's selling something called six figure Sunday.
I guess that's the day you're supposed to work one day a week to make six
figures. Now, if that doesn't already sound preposterous. I mean,
I know it already does. So hold on though. Hold on. Don't click up.
I know it sounds preposterous, but you won't believe what this guy said.
You'll be wondering why haven't the police knocked on this guy's door.
Seriously.
It's unbelievable what this guy tries to hoodwink people with and the fact that
no one's caught him out on it is honestly insane.
1.79 million subscribers and he's Hocking this crazy stuff.
So let's get into what he's promising, what he's guaranteeing.
So we've already gone through him, mocking people who work for a living,
but let's see that again, real quick.
$15 An hour,
$15 an hour.
You work for a living,
but later he tries to redeem himself because he basically insults you right out.
The gate tries to redeem himself.
Well worth $100, $200, three, $500 an hour.
Okay? So this is a smart play. Basically. He's like, look,
if you're not making 500 bucks an hour, like you're worth it. You're worth it,
boss, babe, go get what you're worth. He's saying that it's on you.
If you're not making that kind of money, maybe you you're missing the secret.
Great. And I'm going to show you exactly how to achieve that today.
I am going to show you how to make six figures working from the
beach.
But before I show you how to make six figures a year by working just one day a
week from your laptop. Let me tell you a little about who the hell I am.
Are you kidding, dude? Who in the hell I am.
Nobody cares who the hell you are. Why is he looking so intensely at the camera?
And he's got that like open,
close it piped out. Nobody cares who you are. Okay? You may have 1.7,
9 million subscribers. So technically people already know who the hell you are,
but we don't care. The copy's Zillow army. We don't respect people like you.
My name.
Is Adrian. Grish gone. But for short,
you can simply call me Adrian G and over the past five years
of work, nothing. But one day a week,
I worked a nine to five,
just like you and you and you
and you. I.
The contingent in his face when he's doing this, he's like, Hey,
I used to be a loser. Like you guys, you, you tax support,
loser guide.
You can't see this guy driving a bus loser guy doing construction work loser.
Have you thought about selling? [inaudible] get rich guys Gibbs.
That that is just something I can't stand in this industry.
I'll let this play more in a second. But the belittling of actual work,
while you sit around here and promise empty dreams to people is so
disgusting, dude,
I am sickened by this I'm sickened by this
belittling of real jobs, dude.
It's one of the things that drives me most crazy about this disgusting world of
get rich, quick scheme. It's icky.
Years and years of what I politely defined as hell one day, sir.
So he wasn't, he wasn't belittling it it's hell.
Everything just clicked. I snapped and finally had enough.
So for the sake of time,
I'm going to skip ahead here a little bit and say that he gives you the whole
sob story, right? He goes,
he says that he used to work nine to five jobs just like ear and yeah.
And yeah, Eddie. Yeah. Right. He did that whole sub story. He says,
my boss, he fired me it's he was such a jerk, whatever.
Then I basically found the secret, right? He's going to talk about,
he was destitute. He was, he was about to be homeless. He said, and uh,
one day he was trying to figure out what is he good at our guys.
Finally gonna tell us what the secret is. What's his skill? What, what,
what was his big epiphany?
I had to be something.
I was good at something where I could give value to the world that I was
actually passionate about.
And that's when I received a text message from one of my lady, friends,
Amber that said, Hey, babe, what you up to buckle up boys?
And that's when I had my money-making epiphany.
This is what he's about. He's very passionate about Amber trust.
You see, Amber was a girl I met at the grocery store,
got her number and it happened having some fun with her ever since.
And she was just one of many, many girls on my roster.
All my guy friends would always ask me,
how the hell do you pull so many girls so easily?
I would simply smile, shrug my shoulders and say, I have no idea.
I just sort of do my thing.
Imagine.
Think about yourself and be like, all my guy, friends are like dead.
How you slay so much dead? How did he get so many girls? And I'm just like,
Ugh, I dunno. It's just sort of something I do.
But this is when I realized that I do have a skill
and not just a skill, but a skill that would be valuable to other people,
which is the key.
So while I could never go to school to be a dentist or a surgeon per
se, I guess you could just call me the love doctor.
The love doctor.
I swear guys. Sometimes I really do think to myself,
why isn't everybody in the world talking to me?
Where's puny pie, dude.
This is the love doctor.
I swear when you guys say copies of what's happened to which one you're actually
right. It's criminal. How much fun that I'm having. But anyways, love doctor,
guys practicing without a license doctor.
Because I was as good at picking up chicks as any man walking earth.
But the thing is,
while I had all the knowledge and secrets in the world on how to help guys pick
up women,
there was still no way I could create my own product and package it within two
weeks before I was out of my office from this eviction notice.
Oh yeah. Sorry guys. Uh, I, we got to skip past this.
It's just like the boring sob story about how he was just like, yeah.
He's about to be evicted from his apartment. That's to get your emotions all,
you know, stirred up. Oh, magically. He figured it out. He mastered it.
And that's his way of trying to get you to follow him.
It's because you think to yourself, Oh,
I was just like this guy I'm in a bad spot. Maybe he's holds the secret.
It's a classic copywriting tool. Okay. So now he's going to get into the pitch.
He's going to start selling, selling, selling,
and this is where it gets truly disgusting.
Full, detailed,
easy to use program ever created on how to generate a six figure revenue working
just one day a week, guaranteed.
This isn't a program filled with cheesy. Get rich,
quick schemes for you to follow.
Oh my gosh.
People say that with a straight face without, without doing this,
your program is literally called six-figure Sunday.
In which you teach people to make six figures working one day a week.
If that's not a get rich quick program. I don't, I don't know what is, I mean,
look, you're the love doctor, right? I'm copies Zillow. You're the love doctor.
I'm copies though. I specialize in get rich, quick schemes. I'm sorry to say,
buddy. We've uh, done the math.
It's a get rich quick scheme. I mean, that's what it is. So anyway,
now he's going to talk about, uh, how bosses are evil again. Right?
Cause he really needs to sell you.
Well, I got five. I almost get evicted and ended up homeless.
Honestly. Now that I look back on it,
living like that and letting another man have so much power over me actually
made me less of a man. It's just something I have to admit this.
It's such a scumbag dude.
Why he's doing this is because he's telling you at home. Hey,
if you have a boss, you really kind of, you kind of a baby boy, are you a baby?
If you don't have my program, you're a baby boy.
Because if you let her have a boss have that kind of power over you, dude,
doesn't that make you less of a man? I don't know.
There's this sky. So shameless.
Wait, if I'm being real with myself and besides my boss being the
world's biggest going into work five days a week,
just to make enough money to live. Wasn't too fun in its own, right?
Just an outright dead end job with no extra time or money for leisure.
While all the CEO does is kickback on his luxury yacht sipping
$5,000 bottles of champagne off of my blood, sweat and tears.
Again, this guy is so out to lunch. Did,
that's why I'm going to call BS on him,
probably ever having a job who thinks their boss is doing this dude.
Most CEOs are working their tail off. I mean,
I know it's a meme that they sit back with, like their fat cats and yeah,
they get paid a lot, but they're not sitting on yachts all day.
Sipping $5,000 bottles of champagne.
This is such a cringe overdone trope that these people try to
do. Oh, your boss is just, he's just sitting on the yacht, doing nothing.
Why is he even there when you're, you're doing everything,
it's such a dumb view of how jobs work.
And I want to reiterate again.
I'm sure you've seen other make money programs out there claiming to help you
make $100 million or make 50 K in just seven days.
But this is the difference.
I'm not here to give you false BS expectations. And so your dreams,
Nope, I can't help you make 50 K in only seven days. And no,
I don't guarantee you be able to make 100 million.
But what I can promise is you will be able to make six figures a year
working just one day a week,
which is more than what most humans could ever ask for.
If you're looking to be the next bill Gates or Jeff bays.
Oh you can't shut up. Shut, shut your mouth. When I'm talking,
Hey, you can't, you can't do that. That's illegal.
It should, it should be illegal. Right?
That that's illegal to do what you just did. Hey,
I'm not, I'm not here to promise you get rich quick schemes. Right? Hey. Um,
but I w what I can promise you is that you can work one day a week and make six
figures. This isn't some kind of crazy get rich, quick scheme. Am I right guys?
This guy?
Oh my God.
I've lost it, dude. I've lost the pot. Okay. Let's get,
let's get back into this.
Be honest in this economy.
Oh, I actually, I actually know what part is coming up. Oh,
you guys are going to love this,
this baby by the greatest, get rich, quick scheme video of all time.
Can we get some light in here? It's kind of bothering me. Hold on one second.
Go ahead. Sorry. Sorry to interrupt. You.
Originally planned to give this system away from absolutely free.
That is until I realized such a move would turn out to be
counterproductive. Yeah.
Really? You plan to give it away for free.
I wanted to give it away for free, but it'd be Ghana. I have to charge you guys.
And ruin the mission of what I actually set out to do,
which is helping you make six figures on your own.
Let me explain you.
See if everyone were to download this system for free the
system and skills that teachers would go viral instantly.
Why is this a bad thing? Because once it goes viral,
all the other blogs will steal my powerful secrets and rebrand as a
get rich, quick scheme.
Get rich, quick scheme. I want to tell you it is fun.
Remember, I'm the get rich quick scheme doctor.
And that's when all the lazy poses will attempt to use the system while you the
serious one will pass over it because you think it's just not a
BS system. Like all the other crap floating around out there.
This is such a pathetic attempt to hide the real reason he just wants to make
money. Hey, that's the reason he's not some altruist.
He's not trying to give you secret powerful,
magical formulas out of the kindness of his. So.
Off to some careful deliberation,
I was able to pull some strings and strike the perfect balance on the cost of
the system to ensure I was there.
Really put, Hey, I'm out there fighting for you.
I told the people above me who made the course me.
I told them you can't charge them this much. I swear, dude,
it's unethical to charge them this much. They're broke. They need help.
But at the same time, we have to charge them.
Cause otherwise it would be it'd be go viral instantly. We wouldn't want that.
So I told myself, you better give them a good price.
Every person in need of ditching that boss and making six figures a year
could easily afford it. So today,
for a limited time,
you can access the six figure Sunday system instantly for a one-time
fee of just $497,
which is 78% off the normal price of $2,197.
And once you get your hands on the six biggest Sunday system,
it's going to be like sticking the key in the ignition of a brand new land
became.
Guys, don't worry. Don't forget. This is not a get rich quick scheme.
It's not once you get it.
It is like sticking the keys in the ignition of a brand new Lamborghini.
But remember guys, this isn't like the other crap floating around out there.
In fact, that's why he has to charge you $497 for it truthfully.
And that's that's the end.
He goes and sits down at his desk while wearing board shorts,
I guess to show that, Oh wow, this guy is such a rock star dead.
He doesn't even wear pants. I mean, honestly, I'm not impressed.
That used to be original before COVID now. I mean, it's original to wear pants,
right? Like now I'm the original one actually out here wearing pants.
Oh, and then get this and you start counting money. Gosh, that's so loud.
So aggressive.
So one last thing I want to talk about before we go, like,
I know you already think he's a scumbag, but look, one thing he harps on.
One thing he makes painfully clear is, Oh my gosh,
I'm such a good guy for offering you a guarantee. And by that he means the,
as a money back guarantee,
which most people in the get rich space have actually how this works.
The little insider secret is they have a calculation for Eve.
They know almost nobody. This is going to happen for nobody.
Nobody's going to be working one day a week and getting six figures. Right?
So they know that,
but they also know that not everyone who fails will get a refund,
just it's just odd. So they just count on most people not asking for a refund.
That's how they make their money. But nonetheless, he really tries to hit home.
That man, he's such a good guy.
Biggest companies, 100 billion,
$1 trillion companies like best buy and Amazon only offer
amazingly 15 and 30 day guarantee respectively.
But that's that greedy CEO, corporate BS laughing at you again,
go figure.
Go figure.
I,
Adrian [inaudible] is willing to double,
quadruple their guarantee window because I have zero down mine.
Oh, you're LA. I'm not even going to let you finish this lie. Okay. He says,
Oh man, I'm doubled their offer.
He says that he's got a 60 day money back guarantee refund. Okay.
Let's take that apart. First of all,
I've already explained to you that that's part of their calculation. Right?
But secondly,
it's standard for ClickBank ClickBank at his discretion will allow
for the replacement or return of any product within 60 days of purchase. Stop.
Pretending like you're the good guy. That's just their standard return policy.
Hey yeah. You probably would have tried to get around it if you could.
I mean, don't act like you're some good guy. Oh,
that's the greedy corporate BS, bro.
You were forced to offer a refund. So shut your mouth. Oh wait.
There's more actually. Hey, check out what I just found.
This is the six-figure Sunday's terms of service. Oh, look,
let's look at this updated January of 2019. Okay.
So let's see here. Uh, the refund, oops,
looks like we've got a 30 day refund. Interesting.
And then it's actually an action-based refund. So you have to,
it looks like you have to create a landing page that gets a thousand visits,
which isn't easy to do.
But then check out the little note where the greedy corporate BS guy,
he doesn't do that.
Look at what he does due to the tremendous value throughout the course.
You will not be eligible for a refund if you purchase the six-figure Sunday at a
discount price. So what does that mean? Ladies and gentlemen,
this guy who says I'm not going to do the corporate BS. Well,
it means that no one who buys his product is eligible for any refund.
This guy, this guy, this guy right here,
won't offer you a refund. Look at this guy.
Easily 15 and 30 day guarantee respectively,
but that's that greedy CEO, corporate BS laughing at you again,
go figure I Adrian [inaudible] little
me is willing to double,
quadruple their guarantee window because I have zero doubt in my mind that
six figure Sunday will work for you.
Bro. You literally wrote it in the fine print.
Then nobody's going to read and you know it that you actually can't get a
refund. You lying hypocrite.
That's that greedy carpet Bay bad. Oh man,
this guy is the gift that keeps giving. So anyways guys, um,
I hope you enjoyed this video and uh, you know, I dunno,
subscribe smashed. Like why you do that? I'll uh, be counting,
counting my money. Uh, I actually don't have any money around here. Uh, let,
let me just, let me just let him count them aggressively.
Count the money for me. Just, just join the six figure coffees of the club,
right? Six figures. We're at one 80 subs. Let's see if we.
Can crank that up. Huh? All right. See you next time.
[Inaudible].